haider ist mit ermittlern und auch mit
zeugen gesprochen und es gibt zeugen die
behaupten dass schon vor einiger zeit
christian b ihnen die tat gestanden
hätte
was genau hat es damit auf sich in der
tat gibt es diese menschen patricia sind
nicht gleich zu schwimmen sie sind in
italien haben sie sich haben sie sich
versteckt sind sie abgetaucht sie reden
natürlich nicht gerne mit der presse ist
es uns trotzdem gelungen mit dem einen
oder anderen zu sprechen und ein puzzle
zusammenzusetzen in dem sich eine nacht
ist wichtig für diesen fall heraus
märz 2008 christian b richtige zu einem
techno festival in spanien
was er auf ehemalige sehen wie er mit
den feiernden und umgebung und die hände
sie hatten diesel gestohlen haben
eigentlich und nannte diese männer
unterhielten sich aus baar ist abends
kann nicht sein dass man nicht beim
portugal sein könne dass man hier keine
geschäfte mehr machen können weil alles
von der polizei seien verschwunden
in dieser nacht das hat zumindest ein
freund gegenüber behauptet christian wey
eingeräumt das verschwinden zu tun hat
das war mein herz mich an die alten
fenster hinter mir mehr als 2010
gestellt wie serie sky sind denn diese
zeugenaussagen und die zeugen an sich
das ist ein absolut berechtigte frage
patricia die zeugen haben alle eine
kriminelle geschichte aller einen
kriminellen hintergrund sind allesamt
vorbestraft das ist auch einer der
relevanten punkte den friedrich fällt
schon der verteidiger von kristian weg
immer wieder anspricht
einer der zeugen der nämlich die polizei
zehn jahre nach maddies verschwinden auf
christian beeck aufmerksam machte der
saß da in haft und er wurde nach nach
einer wahl zu sieben jahren verurteilt
worden wurde aber schon nach zwei jahren
entlassen und der märkte recht an
glücklicherweise gab es an dir
möglicherweise hat er da etwas sei es
nur aus den kassen
derzeit allerdings behauptet habe von
seiner strafe ich jeden tag griechenland
einen einen justiz passes wenn man im
gefängnis arbeitet einen tag gefallen
lassen und die anzeige behauptet genau
das taten nur so kurz gesessen aber sich
die sache gelassen da arbeiten anders
geprüft
es gibt diesen passus tatsächlich ist
tatsächlich denkbar
also ich glaube das ist eine andere
hintergrund gibt warum er so spät dass
ausgepackt hat möglicherweise hat er
einfach gewartet bis es sich nicht mehr
selbst belasten muss
wir reden von einem hochgradig
kriminellen kreis von menschen die da
ging es um einbrüche und um drogenhandel
möglicherweise hat er einfach damit
warten wollen bis sie sich selbst etwas
anderes an hängen muss ein weiterer
zeuge und das ist interessant behauptet
dass er bereits im jahr 2008 nach dem
techno-festival die polizei darüber
informiert habe dass christian b
eingeräumt habe dass er etwas mit dem
verschwinden von maddie zu tun hat die
polizei behauptet der zeuge aber ihnen
da aber nicht ernst genommen also
spannende entwicklungen im fall maddie
kai feldhaus vielen herzlichen dank nach
portugal
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren